SHAHID HUSSAIN:
My name's Shahid.
I'm a product
manager on Chrome OS.
I'm here with my colleague,
Ben, and our friends
from Samsung and Gameloft.
And we're going to be
talking to you about building
and making sure that
Android games run well
on screens with devices
with large screens.
So Ben it's going to be
coming on stage shortly
to tell you a
little bit about how
you can make Android games work
well with large screen devices.
Just before he does
that, I'm going
to spend a few minutes
talking about why
you should think about it.
So we at Google spend a lot
of time thinking about gaming,
in part because we have so
many people using Play Store--
and many of those people
do so because they
want to play games.
So we think about what games
people are playing and why
and what games they're going
to be playing two, three, five
years from now.
So as we do that, we're starting
to see more and more titles
that pull players in
with immersive graphics
and immersive gameplay.
And that makes sense to us
because mobile hardware has
grown stronger 3D
capabilities, higher resolution
screens, and the
Android framework
itself has evolved to support
these with modern graphics APIs
like Vulkan.
And those immersive
titles look and play
better on large screen devices.
So we talk about larger screens.
What do we what do we mean?
Well we're really thinking
about four things.
Chromebooks-- that's the
team that I come from--
tablets-- in our case
Android tablets--
devices that have mobile
to desktop extension,
and foldable phones.
And our friend from
Samsung will be telling you
a little bit about that.
So first Chromebooks.
Who here has a Chromebook?
If you could raise
your hand please.
Oh OK.
I have people raising multiple
hands, which is awesome.
So thank you for those of you
who use Chromebook devices.
So for those of you who
are game developers, if you
have a game in the
Google Play Store,
it's probably already
running on Chrome OS.
So I'd definitely recommend,
grab any Chrome OS device,
load it up in the Play
Store, and check it out.
Now the way that
works is Chromebooks
run a full version of
the Android framework
inside a container.
So from a games
perspective, it's just
running on an Android device.
The container connects directly
to input, display, networking,
and so on.
Now you probably
know Chromebooks
as laptops but Chrome
OS, the operating
system that powers that, is
available on a bunch of form
factors--
desktops, all-in-ones,
detachables, and now tablets.
And your input is going to
vary from device to device
your main input on
a laptop is going
to be keyboard and some
kind of pointing device.
But when you go through
all those different types
of devices, it can vary.
Not every device
has a touchscreen
and not every device has
the same kind of input.
Chromebooks are in growth.
According to NPD, Chromebook
market share is growing.
It reached 26%
based on unit sales
in the US as of November 2018.
And year on year
market share grew 34%.
So from our perspective-- and
we hope from your perspective
too--
Chromebooks are a
market that we think
are worth keeping
an eye on, have
grown a ton in the last
four to five years,
and we expect that to continue.
Second, tablets.
So tablets have been around on
Android for a really long time,
since Honeycomb.
And today there's a really
wide variety of devices,
from units that run on Chrome
OS like the Pixel Slate
with a 12 inch screen, premium
devices like the Galaxy Tab S4,
all the way to more affordable
units like the Tab E Lite
7 inch.
Variety of screen sizes.
Variety of cost points.
And Android tablets
we think are key.
So 19% of all
active mobile gamers
play on an Android tablet.
And that includes across
all platforms, both Android
and iOS.
So if you're shipping
a game on mobile,
this is a sizable chunk
of the people who play it.
Third, desktop extension.
So an increasing number of
phones, like many Samsung
flagships since
the S8, allow you
to connect a mouse,
keyboard, and screen,
and extend onto a larger screen.
Usually there's no
touchscreen since you're
on an external display.
And just like Chrome OS, there
exists a multi-window system.
So that app or game, the
window can be resized.
And then finally foldables.
So foldables are coming
to the market soon.
All sorts of interesting
features, like dual display.
And we'll have the
Samsung team talk
about that in more detail in
context of the Galaxy Fold
shortly.
So that's a little bit about
the space and some of the why.
And to talk to you a
little bit about the
how, I'm going to hand
over my colleague, Ben.
BEN GABLE: Hey, everyone.
My name is Ben Gable.
I'm a Partner Developer
Advocate at Google
and ex-game developer.
And I'm here to talk
about, as Shahid said,
some of the common
technical issues
that you need to consider
when bringing your game
and adapting it for these
larger screen devices
So maybe just start
off and show of hands.
How many of you have
actually consciously adapted
your game for larger screen
devices by adding input--
extra input like
keyboard mouse--
or you're handling multiple
aspect ratios or resolutions?
Anybody?
Has anybody done that
with their mobile game?
I see, like, a couple hands.
How many of you are planning
to do that maybe with a game
that you're launching soon
or sometime this year?
Anybody else?
A couple more hands, OK.
So hopefully after this
presentation, a lot more of you
will consider it.
So why is this important, right?
There's all these different
devices out there.
And as Shahid said, your game
is probably already running
on these larger screen devices.
And it's important because,
as game developers,
you obviously want to provide
the best possible gaming
experience for your players.
And so you really need to
consider what kinds of devices
that your players
are playing on.
It could be a phone
in portrait mode.
It could be a
Chromebook or Samsung
DeX with keyboard and mouse
attached, or soon, foldables
with multiple displays,
configurations,
and aspect ratios.
And you know you
want your players,
if they're downloading
on one of these devices,
to have a great experience.
And, you know, it
can really allow
you to expand the fun factor
of your game on these devices.
Now I realize that this
sounds like a lot of work.
And for a lot of
game developers,
the words "new platform"
or supporting something
that's not mobile is definitely
a challenge-- especially
in the Android ecosystem.
But the key thing
to remember here
is that this is
all still Android
and this is all the same APK.
So it's not like you're
shipping a separate APK
for these other devices
and one for mobile.
They're all combined
within one APK.
And there's certainly
things you can
do to adapt that one APK
for things like foldables,
or tablets, or Chromebooks, but
what I want to focus on here
is kind of the best practices,
the stuff in the middle there.
That will give you a great
baseline compatibility
across all these
different devices.
And it's really kind of
boiled down, I think,
to three main areas.
Screen considerations, input
considerations, and kind
of building and
setting up your APK
so that when it's distributed,
it works across the most
devices possible.
And for certain devices,
there's certain areas
that maybe there's
more considerations you
have to think of or deal with.
But if you're going for
the largest compatibility
across all these different
types of large screen devices,
you're going to have to
kind of look at each area.
So how do you handle
this with one APK?
It's going to touch
into this, right?
I mentioned it's the same
APK across all these devices.
How would you handle this?
So very high-level,
you handle this
with configuration changes.
So in Android, if you're not
familiar, anytime the system
detects a device
configuration change,
it's going to automatically
restart your activity
and restart it with
new resources that
allow your app to kind
of change and adapt
for that new configuration.
So the most important task
for you as game developers
to kind of consider is handling
these configuration changes
appropriately so that your game
will run seamlessly across,
no matter what device
it's running on
or what kind of things
happen during gameplay.
By default Android system
will do this automatically.
So a lot of you, if you're
not doing it right now,
you're probably just
living with Android
doing it automatically for you.
It does this by invoking
OnSaveInstanceState
before it will restart
your activity, which
lets you save some
information that you
need to restart your activity.
But for a lot of
resource-heavy games,
this is not ideal
because it would
be really slow to
restart the activity
and reallocate all
those resources.
And in the case of dynamic
resizing on Chromebooks,
it can happen.
You can get a lot of
configuration change
events, at least one per frame.
So it's better to think about
and handle this yourself
so you know exactly how your
game is going to behave anytime
a configuration change happens.
So now I've kind of touched
on the high-level aspects
of configuration changes.
Let's see how we'd
use them to adapt
a game across these
devices, starting
with the screen considerations
I mentioned earlier.
So on devices like
Chromebooks and Samsung DeX,
your game, by default,
is going to be launched
into a windowed environment
where it can be dynamically
resized, which is something
that a lot of mobile developers
don't really consider.
And on devices upcoming like
the Samsung Galaxy Fold,
the screen and aspect
ratio will change
whenever the user opens the
device from the smaller screen
to the larger internal screen.
So each of these cases is
going to fire off and on
configuration changed event.
So to handle this,
you simply need
to declare in your manifest
all the configurations
that you want to handle
yourself dynamically in code.
So in this example,
we're declaring
that we want to handle screen
size changes and orientation
changes.
So then in your code
now, your activity
is going to invoke on
configuration change
whenever the screen size
changes, or the orientation
changes, or whatever other else
configuration that you declare
that you want to handle.
So for example, in this case you
could scale your OpenGL content
to match the new aspect ratio
or resolution to prevent things
like inaccessible UI elements or
change your input areas so they
make sense on the new screen.
So that's maybe how you'd handle
that case with the resizing.
Now if your game is always
intended to run in fullscreen--
which, for some
developers, that's enough--
or maybe you test set
out on a Chromebook
and you find it's crashing
or something else bad is
happening, you can
always prevent your game
from being resizable
by specifying
realizable activity to be
false inside your manifest.
You should also note that if
you do prevent this, however,
split screen will not
work on mobile devices.
And we recommend that
you, if at all possible,
really try to support
the dynamic resizing.
Because a lot of gamers
want to have the game
running with maybe a
Twitch chat or something
else up next to it.
So we think it's a valid
user experience in some case,
so try to support it if you can.
So on the topic of
orientation, on mobile devices,
usually the default
orientation is portrait.
But on other devices,
it could be landscape.
So you should specify in
your manifest the sensor
orientations that you support
so that the system doesn't flip
your game upside down
or something else crazy
happens while people are
kind of moving the device.
If you're dynamically
handling orientation changes
inside your code, make sure
you use Display.getRotation
and be aware that the
values that you're expecting
might be swapped based on the
default hardware orientation.
So another thing to consider
about larger screen size
is obviously the
resolution, right?
There's more pixels
and a bigger screen
means you should probably
provide higher resolution
assets.
One of good tools around this--
You can either handle this
yourself or you can consider
using Android app bundles.
What that will allow you to do
is to upload all of your assets
for all the different
various screen densities,
and then Google Play
will automatically
ship whatever assets are
needed to the particular device
that somebody is playing on.
So for example if somebody
is playing on a tablet,
it's going to emit kind of
the lower resolution assets
or if they're playing
on a mobile device,
maybe it will emit the ultra
high resolution assets.
This really saves you
valuable download space
because it does not go against
your download cap or the size
limit on Google Play.
And it also really
saves you the trouble
of maintaining multiple
APKs for different devices.
So I recommend you look into it.
And again with more pixels
comes more flexibility
with the UI in HUD.
So if players are playing
on a larger screen,
consider the things
you can add, expand,
or change to suit that display.
Also make sure that you
consider how readable
and how big everything
is on a larger display.
So for example, if
somebody is playing on a TV
that they're sitting 6
to 10 feet away from,
make sure all your
fonts are readable
and that all the elements
of your UI are identifiable.
Nothing's more frustrating
than trying to squint
at a small text on a screen.
So that some screen
considerations.
Let's talk about input now.
So more and more
games are delivering
kind of a desktop or
console-like experience, right?
You're seeing all
these games that
are kind of blurring the
line between something you'd
find on Steam or
traditionally, and now it's
being played on a mobile device.
And a lot of those games
are having-- you know,
we're, as game developers,
kind of assuming
that it's going to be played
with a touchscreen or touch
interface.
But you know the
players are going
to be very disappointed
if they load up an FPS
game on their
Chromebook or something
with a keyboard and mouse
attached and it doesn't work.
And, you know,
Android has had APIs
to support keyboards, mouse,
and controllers for a while.
But again, a lot
of game developers
don't consider using
them because they just
assume it's going to be
a touchscreen device.
So the other thing
to keep in mind
is that many of these
devices are convertibles.
So they can switch
configurations on the fly.
So a good example
is a Pixelbook,
where it can be in
clamshell laptop mode,
and then the player
can switch it
to a tablet in the
middle of gameplay.
So really try to anticipate
all the different ways
that the configurations
could change
during gameplay and support
kind of on the fly control
scheme changes.
And again, we come back to kind
of configuration changes right
how do you detect this
and how do you handle it.
So the best way is to specify
in your manifest configuration
changes around input
devices such as keyboard
and handle these on the fly
and switch the control schemes
based on what configuration
change events you're
getting inside of your code.
So there's many ways
to do this, but one
of the ways you can do it
is basic query InputManager
at startup, for example, or
during a configuration change
and kind of pull the system
to see what hardware input
devices are available.
And also make sure
they're usable, right?
Because just because an input
device might be available,
it might not be usable.
Because it could be a
Chromebook, for example, where
it's in tablet mode and
the keyboard is there
but it's not usable because
it's on the back of the device.
So it's really important
to consider this and adjust
this on the fly and just adapt
to whatever is usable currently
during gameplay.
And Asphalt 9 here does
a great job of this.
And Alex will be talking
about this a little bit later.
And if you don't
think keyboard support
makes sense for
game, fair enough.
There's a lot of games out
there that work extremely
well just touch but
you might consider
that it improves accessibility
if you do add keyboard support.
So things like skill key
bindings, player navigation,
menu navigation, camera control.
You know, there's lots
of different things
you can do to just give
players a little bit
of interesting shortcuts or
improves the way that they
interact with your game.
If you really
wanted to get fancy,
you could also implement
custom key mappings
and let players set up
exactly how they want
to be able to play the game.
Another thing you should
not forget about is mice.
So use the Android APIs.
We've got APIs
for mouse capture,
where you can basically
capture the mouse
in the center of the screen,
which works extremely well
for third person-type
games or FPSs
where you want the cursor
to be locked in the middle.
You can request to
capture the mouse pointer.
It'll disappear while
still sending you
kind of the motion
events you need
to move the camera
around or the player.
So this is a key
thing that will really
make those first person
shooter-type games
or third person
controlled cameras really
that much more
usable on Chromebooks
because trying to do that
with a touchpad or touchscreen
doesn't work so
well all the time.
And if you haven't implemented
controller support,
please consider that as well.
A lot of people are using
controllers more widely
across devices like
Chromebooks and Samsung DeX,
and all the standard
Android controller APIs
work across these devices.
So it's another great
way to make sure
that you're just providing
one more option for players
to enjoy your game.
So that's some screen
and input considerations.
Now let's talk about how you
set up your APK in Build Time
and configure it to
make sure that it
supports all these various
devices running Android.
So first off you need to review
your permissions and features
that you're asking
for and determine
if you really need them.
There are some
permissions and features
that are not supported
on certain devices
like Chromebooks, so if
you blindly ask for them,
you might get in a
situation where somebody
tries to go download your
game on the Play Store
and it says it's not
compatible with that device.
And sometimes it's not
very clear to the users
why it's not supported.
So good examples of this
might be GPS, or SMS,
or even rear-facing cameras.
So what we recommend
is that you list
them is not required
in your manifest
and then, in code, just check to
see if you have that permission
or if that hardware
feature is available
and handle it gracefully in code
rather than just declaring it
as required at download time
Also consider the hardware
that you're running on.
So a lot of these devices
have very different levels
of performance And so if you
have an automatic quality
control system, you
should try to test it
on on lower-end hardware
and on more beefier hardware
to see how it behaves and
make sure it's doing the thing
that you expect.
If you kind of support things
like different performance
quality profiles, consider
adding some for beefier devices
like Chromebooks
and just adapt them
to optimize for the device
performance potential
that it has.
Because when players are
playing on a more expensive
or device with a
larger screen, they
might expect that it kind of
looks better as there's more
fancy graphics features there.
Additionally, try to provide
an x86 build if you can.
I know a lot of developers
are only providing ARM.
But consider that most
Chromebooks are x86 so
providing x86 or
x86_64 builds is
going to give you a
little bit of boost
in performance on those devices.
Because otherwise, you'll
have to have your ARM binary
translated to run that system.
So you'll incur a little
bit of an overhead
when it automatically does that.
And for those of you looking
to get the maximum graphics
performance, a lot of these
devices now support Vulkan 1.0.
1.1 coming soon.
So please look into that
because usually it'll
give you a bigger boost in
speed when running, especially
these larger screens.
And finally, test across
all these devices.
So add test cases
that cover things
like minimizing, maximizing,
resizing, switching
between the smaller
and larger screens.
You really want to
see how your game is
going to behave across all
these different configuration
changes.
Not only that, but
maybe there's something
you're doing with
Unreal or Unity,
or your custom engine
that, you know,
something bad might
happen at that level.
So you want to make sure you're
testing to see if there's
any potential problems.
I know that QA
resources can be tight
and game developers are
always trying to push content
as fast as possible--
quality content.
So please try to use things
like Android Studio, Android
and Chrome
[INAUDIBLE] simulators
to get a good sense of
how your game might behave
in a short amount
of time, or you
could consider looking at
something like Firebase Test
Lab, where you can automate
the testing process
and get reports based on
devices in the cloud there.
So it's really important
to test and make sure
that your game is
doing what you think
or what you expect it is across
all these different device
configurations.
So now that I've
covered the basics,
I'm really excited to welcome
our friends, Ash and Nawoong
from Samsung, to come
up and talk a lot more
about the Samsung Galaxy Fold.
ASH SHARMA: Thanks, Ben.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Ash.
I'm a Partner Support
Engineer at Samsung.
I'm here with my
colleague, Nawoong,
and today we are going
to talk about how
you can make your game
work great on Galaxy Fold.
We'll be talking about
some general specs
and touch on a few concepts
like app continuity
and multi-resume.
As you know, we announced
Galaxy Fold on February 20th.
It introduces a
completely new category
that unlocks new capabilities
never seen before with Infinity
Flex Display.
We created Galaxy
Fold for those that
want to experience what a
premium foldable device can do,
beyond the limitation of
a traditional smartphone.
Galaxy Fold is an a
category of its own.
It delivers a new kind
of a mobile experience,
allowing users to do
things they couldn't
do with an ordinary smartphone.
Galaxy Fold is a culmination
of eight years of research
and innovation,
following the debut
of Samsung's first flexible
display prototype in 2011.
It will be available
starting April 26th.
Here are some important
hardware specs.
Galaxy Fold is loaded
with a 7 nanometer
64-bit optical processor,
12 GB of dedicated
RAM, over 4,300
milliampere battery,
providing users with
unmatched gaming potential
that can last for hours
on a single charge.
Now when gaming with Galaxy
Fold, bigger is better.
Games are up to 1.62 times
bigger in landscape and 2.4
times bigger in portrait
than Galaxy S9+,
providing gamers with the most
immersive gaming experience
anywhere.
Seamless app experience.
Player can receive a text invite
to join a multiplayer game
and unfold the response
right into the action.
Multi-active window experience.
Galaxy Fold offers
gamers the ultimate setup
to play your
favorite multiplayer
game while streaming on YouTube
and learning about excelling
how to-- one second.
OK.
Give me one second.
OK, thank you.
OK so multi-active
window experience.
Galaxy Fold offers gamers
the ultimate setup.
Play your favorite multiplayer
game while streaming
on Twitch and
YouTube, playing games
tips for you to master
your competition.
Performance.
Galaxy Folds keep up
with the heaviest gaming
with it's over 4,300 milliampere
battery, carbon water cooling
system, so you can game
stronger and longer.
Now on top of things that
Google already covered,
here are four things
to keep in mind
while designing your
apps for Galaxy Fold
or optimizing your existing app.
Number one, unique aspect
ratio for Galaxy Fold.
Two, display cut out.
Three, app continuity.
Four, free app multi-resume.
We are going to cover
these in detail now.
Supporting fullscreen
mode is critical to ensure
that users get the best
immersive experience.
In your app, take full
advantage of the bigger
display with no black bars.
Let's see how you
can achieve this.
When folded, Galaxy Fold
will have a longer aspect
ratio of 21:9.
For supporting fullscreen,
you will have three options.
One, if your app target SDK
is greater or equal to 26,
then it will run
in fullscreen mode.
But if that's not
an option for you,
then set resizable
activity as true.
This will also enable
multi-window mode for your app.
In our upcoming slide, we will
be covering this in detail.
Resizable activity
as true or false
could be set in activity
or application tag
in your manifest file.
Now if this, too,
is not an option,
then the last resort is to add
maximum aspect ratio of 2.4,
as the cover screen
aspect ratio is 21:9.
This metadata needs to sit
under an application tag
and will allow your
application to take
full advantage of fullscreen.
Next is the display cutout.
Galaxy Fold has a display
cutout when unfolded,
in the top left corner.
Make sure your app is
properly handling the cutout
and no necessary
information is obstructed
because of that cutout.
In the highlighted
portion in this image,
you can see the cutout.
The good news is that there
are standard Android APIs
and that can be
used to make sure
that your app is optimized to
properly handle these screen
cutouts.
Later in our slides, we
will share the resources
and important links that
you can follow to access
the relevant Android APIs.
Now to go through the
details, depending
on the fact whether your
app renders in cutout area,
your app can use
getDisplayCutout API
to retrieve display
cutout objects.
These APIs let you check
whether your content overlaps
in the cutout so you can
reposition if needed.
You can set layout
in display out mode
to one of the following values.
MODE_DEFAULT.
This is the default behavior.
And this content renders
into the cutout area
while in portrait
mode but content
is letterbox while
in landscape mode.
MODE_SHORT_EDGES.
Content renders into the
cutout area in both portrait
and landscape mode.
MODE_NEVER.
Content never renders
in the cutout area.
Here's the code
snippet showing how
to implement short edges
in a style.xml file.
In short edges, content
renders into the cutout area
in both portrait
and landscape mode.
All right.
Now I'm going to invite my
colleague, Nahwoong, to talk
in detail about app
continuity and multi-resume.
Thank you.
NAWOONG HAN: OK.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Nahwoong and I
developed Samsung's Android
framework.
I'm going to explain some
important things for you
to keep in mind about
foldable devices.
First have continuity.
With the foldable
devices, now developers
will be able to control
multiple displays
on a single mobile device.
Users will have a more enriched
mobile experience going back
and forth between displays.
Here Google Maps demonstrates
our app continuity.
The user experience is
unfolded from the cover display
to the immersive
or main display.
That the map information will
be laid out in a bigger display.
Also information which you
are looking for at the cover
display will be
seamlessly transitioned
to the main display.
But to ensure this
wonderful experience,
your apps must be
prepared accordingly.
These are the
requirements that need
to be met to ensure the
desired app continuity.
First apps need to be able to
handle two physical screens.
Second apps need to properly
handle folding and unfolding.
It means handling with
the screen size changing.
Last because of
physical screen size
changing, we strongly
recommend apps to be resize.
As you already know, the Galaxy
Fold is a foldable device.
What does this mean?
Foldable device can
physically fold its display
changing its screen
size accordingly.
This is why Galaxy Fold has
two different screen properties
for the two different screens.
You can check more
detail on the screen.
How can you handle these
two different screen sizes?
This is no different
from other methods
of supporting different
screen sizes on Android
because the Galaxy Fold is a
member of the Android family.
The only difference is
that it will be happening
much more at Galaxy Fold.
Once both the screen sizes
have been properly handed,
the app needs to react
to folding and unfolding.
For the Galaxy Fold,
developers do not
need to handle any
special APIs, nor events
for folding and unfolding.
Galaxy Fold follows conventional
Android platform behavior
for screen size changing.
Due to the screen size
changing, the configuration
will be changed
to the following.
ScreenSize, smallestScreenSize,
and screenLayout.
Again this is no different
from other methods
of handling computer changing.
As Ben already covered
with this topic,
developers can save
and restore data
or handle resizing with
changes to the computer.
Three, to ensure this seamless
experience between displays,
we strongly recommend
the app be resizable.
Once again, this is because
two physical displays have
two distinct screen properties.
Once a resizable app property
handles the changed configures,
the user will have an intuitive
and seamless transition
between the cover and
the main displays.
Foldable devices add a next,
new wave of mobile devices.
More and more will be
released into the market
in coming months and years.
Be prepared for this
movement earlier
and make your apps
easily resizable.
Sooner is always better.
Next point is multi-resume.
Multi-resume means resuming
all top visible activities
in multi-window.
In Android Pie, if
app and OEM opt in,
all top visible
activities are resumed.
Multi-resume is expected to
become mandatory behavior
in next version of Android.
Of course Samsung opted in
this feature with our devices.
All Samsung devices have Android
Pie, including Galaxy Fold,
support multi-resume.
Well applying multi-resume
is also super easy.
Just add the metadata into
manifest file of yours,
just like this.
Then, your app is top-visible.
With a multi-windows situation,
your activity will be resumed.
App developers can now
test how their apps respond
in a folding environment.
This enables them to verify
that it's done correctly
by using an emulation
[INAUDIBLE] that
is provided for app
continuity and multi-resume.
Please check more details
on our resources site.
OK.
So far we have explained several
configurations for Galaxy Fold.
Please remember this.
Galaxy Fold is also
an Android device.
If you follow standard
Android principles
for different devices
and form factors,
there is no problem
with Galaxy Fold.
This is why we collaborate
with Google on this project
since the beginning.
Here is their gaming
experience on Galaxy Fold.
I took this video
from our partners
at Gameloft who work very
closely with the Galaxy Fold.
Now I'd like to welcome Alex,
a Senior Developer for Gameloft
to share their experience
developing multi devices.
Thank you and enjoy the video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ENGINES REVVING]
NAWOONG HAN: By the
way, I played the game.
And did you recognize that
this place is San Fransisco?
It's a little bit long before
you see the iconic Golden Gate
Bridge.
But you just wait.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Did you see that?
OK.
Here is Alex.
Thank you.
ALEJANDRO URBANO:
I'm Alex Urbano.
I'm a Graphics Engineer
at Gameloft Barcelona.
And I'm going to talk
about some high-level ideas
that we followed
to make the Asphalt
9 a truly multi-device game.
So first of all, you
probably already knew
but Asphalt 9 is
an arcade racing
game with a lot of cool,
expensive, real supercars
racing at crazy speeds in
beautiful, real life locations.
It's a great game.
So you should play, please.
So as a mobile center
studio, you usually
think about these
things when building
your game, which are basically
hardwired core constraints.
But that's not true and
it shouldn't be like that.
Because nowadays, you need
to support a wide variety
of devices with many
different input methods
and a huge range of
performance levels.
And that's OK.
You should get as
many devices as you
can to reach as much
people as you can.
So for us, it was really helpful
to develop for an unknown
device with all the possible
options and variations
and invest in a really good
platform [INAUDIBLE] software
that allows the programmers
to work without platform
specifics--
some sort of simulator.
So in the context
of user input, you
need to know what
the user wants.
So don't assume your input
method based on the device.
Detect each input
device there and use
the one that makes sense in
your game and the playing
intentions-- and by
the playing intentions,
I mean that, for
example, if they
have a controller
connected to the device,
it's because probably
they want to use it.
And the specific
input device can
be disconnected at any
time for whatever reason.
You should be able to
adapt to that situation
without interfering too
much in the gameplay.
So for example, pausing the
game as soon as the device
gets disconnected, and
then reconnect for me.
And of course you
should always let
the user choose between the
available input methods.
But be careful with generic
UI control mechanics.
Its device has its own
dynamics and some interactions
may not make sense at
all in all of them.
So moving onto UI.
What we can say is
invest in your tools.
In our case, we chose to
develop our own UI editor
and it's called Gin.
We name all our tools
after drinks for reasons.
And this is used in all
Gameloft Barcelona projects
and allows us to design,
implement, and test
all the UI-related
assets in the game.
So now I'm going to briefly go
through some of its features
so you can see how
we work with it.
Gin has an integrated
source image management
tool that allows the artists
and designers to import
high quality, high
resolution images
in the most popular formats.
So we impose minimal
restrictions here
as they can apply some
optimizations later.
So as a first
optimization step, we
can group those images based
on the usage, the context
inside the game or if they
are in some menu or something.
On quality
requirements, this helps
with loading memory
and quality management.
And this is when the
user decides which
compression profile to use.
I'm going to go to that later.
And if they want to create
any maps for the atlas.
Those limits are
used in case you're
using a low resolution device.
And it helps with flickering
and pixel crawling.
We can also animate every
element or widget using
either GIF animations or events
for sounds and [? particles. ?]
This is greatly of use
by designers and artists
and are a very
important part of how
we have some kind of animation.
Also as a way to
improve productivity,
there's a template system.
This is used to create
the reusable layout
configurations that can
be filled with content.
This, of course,
saves a lot of time
creating new similar
screens or menus
and makes it easier to
keep a consistent look
throughout the whole game.
So as we mentioned before
in the previous parts,
there are lots of different
devices you need to support.
So one of the main challenges
when designing UI is
how to handle the wide variety
of aspect ratios and pixel
densities they have.
In our case, for Gin, we
can offer all the menus
in the specific
key aspect ratios
directly in the [INAUDIBLE].
And we can swap between
them at any time.
We have the most
common [INAUDIBLE]
devices we target
available [INAUDIBLE]..
You should never put UI elements
in absolute positions or sizes.
All our widget positioning is
done in ratios or percentages,
either relative to the screen
or a container hierarchy.
And the size is
translated into pixels
later [? on in rendering ?]
using the device-reported DPI.
But in extreme situations,
when there is no other choice,
we admit defeat and allow
the use of letterboxes.
But this is only done for the
content that really needs it.
The [INAUDIBLE] of the game
is always correctly visible
and it adapts to
any aspect ratio.
So I'm no designer but
I asked our UX team
for some general tips to
take into consideration
when designing the UI that
you might find helpful.
So sometimes the extreme
differences in input methods
impact navigation's
flow and comfort.
In those cases,
you will probably
need to redesign
the layout to make
it work with a specific
input device in mind.
Localization can impose some
strong restrictions in design.
There are significant
size differences
depending on the language
used and you need
to be able to test it quick.
In some languages,
there are also
characters that don't
match particular styles.
For example, a common example
is numerals in some languages.
So it's important to adapt them.
And then this
probably belongs more
to the investing in tools part.
But allow your users
and programmers
to forget about local
conventions like dates, units,
or currencies.
Make a way to do the
conversion internally
to make it look good not
only at the language level
but on different levels too.
For example, in this
particular example,
only the third option
allows the programmers
to forget about formatting
and let them express clearly
the type of data
they want to use.
Regardless of the aspect
ratio, use natural scrolling
whenever it's possible.
Natural, meaning in the dominant
direction of the aspect ratio.
Because, when
scrolling, you usually
focus on the center of
what you are scrolling
but previous and
next elements are
part of the past and future
of what you are exploring.
So those elements are
going to be easier
to go back to
inputting information
or anticipate the new one.
If you see it, those
are [INAUDIBLE]..
Static screens are boring
but don't be too intrusive.
And you can use those animations
to guide the user's attention
where needed.
In our case, that
would be the store.
And this is probably
my big part.
Of course UIs need to be fast.
There's few things as
frustrating as trying
to interact with
an app to find out
that it lags and doesn't do
what you wanted when you wanted.
So be careful with
rendering performance.
This is obvious but
UX can be very complex
with lots of semi-transparent,
animated layers.
Geometry is usually
not the problem.
We are probably talking
about hundreds or thousands
of polygons.
But draw closer, especially
on portable devices.
[INAUDIBLE]
And of course, on
especially mobile,
be careful with fillrate.
Lots of big, transparent
objects can really, really
hit performance.
So use as many
opaque objects as you
can because they can activate
some not obvious hardware
optimizations.
If the platform supports it
and it's widely available,
use framebuffer_fetch
or equivalent
on each API for efficient
programmable blending.
You can also use it to implement
some popular Photoshop-like
blending modes that
could be harder
to achieve using normal hardware
for lending capabilities.
And lastly image compression
is key for good performance.
We're not listing
group of images
based on the compression needs.
In our case, we basically
have four different profiles,
shown here in
increasing quality.
And you probably notice that we
treat alpha separately and this
because, in many situations when
using semi-transparent images,
it is better to
preserve as much quality
as you can on the edges.
And then I'm going to give it
back to Ben so he can finish.
Thank you.
BEN GABLE: Thanks, Alex.
So let's kind of sum up here
what we talked about today.
So hopefully, listening
to all the speakers today,
you guys have realized that
Android gaming is not just
phones anymore.
It's not just what you
think of traditionally
as mobile devices.
You know, players are
experiencing your game--
probably right now--
on a wide variety of devices,
and form factors, and screen
sizes.
And it might seem like
a lot of different stuff
to consider, but again, the
key thing I want to stress--
It's all just Android.
And it's the best
practices for Android.
And by spending just a little
bit of time considering
these use cases, you
really can take your game
beyond just the mobile
device, and adapt it
for all these larger screens,
and provide that best possible
gaming experience across
all these devices.
And that's really important
because your players will thank
you for it and they'll think
that this game is amazing
when they boot it
up on a Chromebook
or they boot it up on
a Samsung Galaxy Fold.
You know, we're really
committed to making
this process easier for game
developers moving forward.
So we've got a number of things
that are kind of in-flight
in coming to help support
you guys in supporting these
devices, such as Crostini,
some developer tools on Linux
on Chromebooks, additional
profiling tools,
emulator improvements-- so you
guys can test a wide variety
of cases--
and further game
controller support
for these different devices.
So we've got a lot
of information.
Please check out our links here.
I'll let you guys
take a picture of it.
But we've got one
for the Android site
and then another
one specifically
on supporting Samsung
Galaxy Fold and foldables
from Samsung.
And I want to say thank you
all very much for coming today.
I hope it was informational.
I hope you guys
learned something.
I hope you kind of consider
these larger screen
devices moving forward.
I want to thank our friends
at Samsung and Gameloft
for coming to speak as well.
We're not going
to do Q&A up here
but if you have any questions,
please come up to the podium
here and grab us
after the session.
Happy to talk more about
anything you guys might want.
So again, thanks very much.
Please fill out the survey as
well for this month's session.
Love to hear some feedback,
positive or negative.
And I hope you guys have
a great rest of GDC.
Thank you very much.